hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round six of the
Kashima of Memorial we said that we are
going to show one more and then check
out the standings it's certainly a
character in verses which monitor none
and soul former Watchers championship
challenger versus former world champion
and it's a really an interesting game
it's hard to say who surprised who who
prepared for who here but you'll see
what I mean by this
so they repeat the same line that was
played by a crossing Khurana in the
World Chess Championship match and it's
also the same line that cousin already
played against Anand in the gushie
memorial here now a few runs ago at the
game crossing one we've already seen it
I will put it in the description below
if you haven't checked it out but I will
also put the game cross and vs Khurana
game 2 from there watch a championship
match if you are a bit more interested
in the line that's being played in the
opening but ok without further ado let's
check it out
Kerrigan has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 now we already seen this
line plenty of times
c4 we have e 6 9 2 3 D 5 Queens gambit
declined is on the board Knight to c3
Bishop to e7 and now bush of the f4 of
the Horowitz attack
we have castles by Anand with III and c5
so everything the same as in Carlson
Caruana
or Carlsen Anand in this here tournament
D captures and c5 Bishop captures and
the Queen to c2 Knight to c6 rook to d1
and now Queen to a5 a3 everything
completely the same as in Carlson versus
Caruana and well Carlsen versus Anand in
this tournament and here rook to d8
there's also a game mama D our vs. on
and maybe Kerrigan was also following
this game
Anand plated against mama D are also
with the black pieces in last year in
2008 in Paris rapid tournament one of
the grand chest towards legs were on and
played rook to e8 but here again hun
goes for Luke to d8 following the cross
and Caruana game and here in the
tournament cross and went Bishop to e2
against Anand the the game that costs an
one but here we have nice to d2 so here
Karen goes into the sharpest possible
line of this opening it's the one that
Costin avoided in the world chess
championship match as it's really insane
and it just allows black a powerful
attack so here Anand is well Kara Kane
is saying to Anand I I know this line
from the water champion geometric much
better than you do so feel free to come
at me with everything you have and iron
the does d4 we already covered this line
as one of the possible lines that did
not happen in the World Chess
Championship match but here it does
happen so tonight the b3 attacking the
Queen and the bishop but would have
Queen to b6 now you have to keep an eye
on the bishop and the now nice day for
with yet another attack against the
queen and the bishop this was a White's
idea with the Riemann hoovering of the
Knights and now Bishop to b4 check this
is all strongest and this is all a
well-prepared line by both of them we
have a a character son before with as
the king was in check this is the
strongest with Queen captures on b4 and
now comes Knight the d2 blocking check
and also the Queen now guard the knight
on a four so what's the idea why did
black sacrifice a piece here
well first he v just attacking the
bishop and preparing to develop the
light square bishop with Bishop to g5
and now Queen to a5 making room for the
night on before to increase the activity
of the night by attacking the Queen
Queen to b3 and now just nice to be four
and already you can see that - maybe
ideas like Bishop to f5 followed by
Bishop to c2 are possible for the moment
they're not as a wife can always block
the bishop with E 4 so first white
illuminates the night busts open the
Kings position Bishop captures with G
captures and now Bishop to e2 Kerrigan
is well in a hurry to Castle you don't
want to allow the position to open up
while your king is still in the center
with Bishop to d7 now threatening to win
back will win back material and also win
the exchange here by by the extent so
first look to a1 defending the knight
and now comes D captures on e3 by Island
F captures on e3 and now you can see
that Anand came fully prepared for this
game b5 and here Kerrigan has to make a
choice does he wanna go
to an even sharper line by actually
capturing the pond here because now you
aren't is a threat sorry I'm this
threatening to win denied an a4 or you
could just castle the safety if you
decide to play something like C capture
some b5 then you get Bishop to e6 with
an attack on the Queen Queen to d1 and
now rook 8 to see it and black has so
much activity here even if white castles
knights the c2 is coming the rook on a1
is under attack at the pond and e3 is
under attack and the white were a black
would really gain a lot of initiative
for for the sacrificed material so here
after b5 kurakin is not interested in
this line he just castles to safety and
says you can have your piece back on and
I'm done playing this well crazy line
so with B captures on a4 Queen to c3 now
on and grabs back material and we have
f5 now knight Knight to f3 going after
the e5 pawn and now just f6 again one of
the positions were it were it is okay to
play f6 we have Knights to h4 and now
just Knight back to c6 offering a trade
of Queens and centralizing the night and
well the blacks position of the King is
a bit more loose so on kirkin decides
not to trade Queens we have Queen back
to a3 with maybe some ideas of
infiltrating we are Queen to b6 but we
have efore now just a nice nice move in
the center we are the pawn making room
on a 5 which will be a very nice outpost
for tonight and also later maybe the
knight can come to d3 or if you know
things get really crazy maybe even to f3
we'll see how it goes
Bishop to d1 I'm going after the a4 pawn
and now in just the night Stewie 5 we
have Bishop captures on a4 sorry first
Queen captures on a for Queen captures
Bishop characters and now rook captures
on a4 and here and just pushes f4 which
is a nice idea if rook captures
then you can infiltrate with rook to d1
if pawn captures then just Knight to b3
we'll have an excellent outpost for the
night and black like either way wants to
get rid of the doubles point so first
hurricane ignores at c5 cargo
has a past c-pawn and he wants to push
it as far as possible doesn't want to
leave it as a target if he manages to
get before him it will be very good for
him
so f captures an e3 by Anand rook
captures on e4 and now comes Luke 88
going after the b2 pawn rook captures on
e3 rook captures on b2 and now just h3
Kara can create some breathing room for
his King we have looked the c2 now or
putting the rogue behind a passed pawn
whether it's your own phone or your
opponent's pawn and now rook captures on
f6 by Kerrigan and the rook captures on
c5 of course eliminating it so here you
can see that Anand has two points one of
them is a passed pawn and Harkin has two
points on the King side material is
completely equal but white is a little
bit better as Islands King is a well
it's a bit he's a bit loose and there
are all the rooks are still on the board
so rook to a six blocking islands passed
pawn preparing to capture it we have
Knight to c6 defending the pawn and all
just nice to have three preparing to
bring the knight into the game look the
c8 now under doubles up on the C file
and now rook the e6 with a double attack
against the knight not really an
important issue now as the knight is
protected
rook to c7 they're protecting the
seventh rank and now King to h2
hurricane just improves the position of
his King King to g7 and now comes looked
a for switching the rooks attention over
to the King side we have h5 not allowing
the roof to occupy g4 and now we have
route back to a 6 as well Ruby g4 is no
longer possible
and here Knights the e7 by anand with
Knight the d4 by Kerrigan and here
Knights the f5 offering a trade of
nights but kurakin declines we have my
not the C 3 and not 2 F 3 but night
Stewie - retreating hoping to go for f4
and h5 and here we have looked a c4 by
Anand here but the best idea is King to
g8 adjust you have to have this option
of rook to g7 if rho v g6 check is
played but here i don't place look the
sea for taking care of the d4 and
therefore square not allowing hurricanes
knights to enter the
but he allows a lot of activity to
Kirkenes rooks look to g6 check is
played King to f8 and now rook the g5 if
check then rook and simple blocker would
work to f7 so first rook to g5 we have
Knights the g7 now defending d h5 pawn
and now comes Luke to f6 check
rook to f7 just blocking and now rook to
h6 with ideas of infiltrating via rope
to h8 so first King to e7 getting out of
the way and now all the way to a5
threatening to capture an a7 King back
the I ate and now comes a rook to h8
check we have looked to f8 and now comes
look to h7 threatening to win denied the
knight cannot move as you lose the h5
pawn so you have to defend it once again
we have looked at f7 but now believe it
or not although it seems like a
perfectly composition on a kurakin has a
winning idea here so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this winning
idea I'll give you a couple of seconds
don't have any water I forgot to pour
for some fresh water so I will just wait
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just won a very
nice endgame that you know came from the
World Chess Championship preparation and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
rook c5 check a very nice idea because
now if you go King to f8 you get rocket
checkmate
so you can't go to f8 obviously and if
you go to the D file which you must you
can't block or or else rook captures and
you lose the night and here in the game
King to d8 was played and now well of
course you all see what happens rook
captures on h5 and it was after look
captures on h5 on move if you do that to
be found on are not resigned the game
what if you resign well he's done upon
he overlooked this so I can imagine that
he was well I even annoyed by this if
you capture just rook captures I mean
it's not a lot you're done one point but
your king is completely cut off from the
game and you will not be able to do all
that much with your which are which are
passed pawn
in once he starts pushing his to
connected passports it's it's over
Anand knows that this is a completely
winning position and he does doesn't
even try to play it hoping for some sort
of a blunder from kurakin and if you
don't if you don't capture the rook then
you don't really have any good options
let's say Ruby seven I just worked a
five-block in the pawn and now you can
still play it with the rooks but still
it's it's a much better position for
white will will be winning and both of
them notice Sam it's really really
interesting and it's hard to hard to say
who who actually prepared for kuku here
because this is the second time in this
tournament that Anand is playing World
Chess Championship preparation with the
black pieces first against Carlsen he
was that game and then against Corrigan
he lost this game as well so it's really
as you can see you can as you can
imagine Caruana did extremely well
against Carlsen in the World Chess
Championship match with with these lines
very well prepared and he he handled it
well precisely as you can see there are
really wild lines and even kirkin
declined that line where he could have
kept the extra piece he gave back the
extra piece he just wanted to accounting
and Indian he he came on Top Chef really
crazy game I really enjoyed it I hope
you did as well I would like to thank
Jeff graves lf-lc be chess club Akashi
and go josh josh bloch grind rod and
buzz better for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you checked with my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon with some more
interesting content hopefully and before
we forget these are the standings after
round six I almost forgot Karlsson still
in the lead but car cane occur up to him
after this victory over Anand four
points for both Carlson and Corrigan
after round six followed by a lot of
people with three points we have anand
navara being gripped apollo under a job
of all of them with three points and in
last place with two points sakura media
of and an onigiri so tough tough
tournament for both mamedyarov and
onigiri former former members of the
2800 club really just you know in
saying world this world of chess it
would seem so I think you'll I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your Saturday